la russie exhorté les états unis à
cesser d'aggraver la crise russo
occidentale autour de l'ukraine un appel
qui intervient au lendemain de la
décision américaine d'envoyer trois
mille soldats supplémentaires en europe
de l'est des militaires qui seront
déployés en pologne et en roumanie en
soutien aux forces de l'otan les
précisions avec notre correspondant à
washington
thomas boyer
le pentagone a officialisé ce mercredi
le déploiement de 3000 soldats
américains à destination d'europe de
l'est 3000 soldats en plus des 8500
militaires déjà placées en état d'
alerte et prêts à être déployés eux
aussi en cas d'activation d'une action
conjointe de l'otan alors ses 3000
soldats américains vont être déployés
ces prochains jours
majoritairement en pologne mais aussi en
allemagne et en roumanie alors dans le
détail mille soldats actuellement en
poste en allemagne vont être déplacées
en roumanie d'ailleurs le porte parole
du pentagone elle salue le fait que la
france va également envoyer des troupes
en roumanie et puis 2000 autre soldat
américain veut faire le déplacement
depuis les états unis à destination
d'europe de l'est notamment en pologne
alors le pentagone souligne le fait que
ces mouvements sont temporaires et que
ces soldats n'ont pas pour but de
combattre en ukraine mais de renforcer
la sécurité des pays membres de l'otan
alors la question a été posée au porte
parole du pentagone pourquoi un tel
déploiement militaire maintenant et bien
selon lui il s'agit d'un message fort
adressé à destination de vladimir
poutine et plus généralement à
destination du monde entier pour
expliquer que l'otan compte pour les
états unis écoutez le ici jen est ce que
nous voyons ce sont des preuves chaque
jour qu'ils continuent de déstabiliser
la région en ajoutant de nouvelles
forces dans la partie ouest de son pays
et tout au long de la biélorussie en
plus d'activités navale dans tehran est
et la mer north atlantic en est
clairement en train de se doter de
plusieurs options de capacité pour
quelle raison nous ne le savons pas
encore et c'est parce que nous ignorons
ses intentions que nous voulons être sûr
d'être prêt à défendre nos alliés sur le
front de l'otan
un déploiement militaire américain
vivement critiqué du côté de moscou lé
vice ministre russe des affaires
étrangères alexandre grouchko fustige
une mesure je cite injustifiée
destructrice augmentant les tensions
militaires et réduisant dit il le champ
pour les décisions politiques